everything we did on screen was dictated
by the story and when we took the story
on it's based on a series of books by
william joyce the children's book author
and illustrator who came up with a whole
new set of mythologies and histories for
all these characters because his
daughter once asked him if santa claus
and the easter bunny knew each other
and uh
you know it when you take on something
like that you're kind of duty-bound at
least we felt to
make this the story and the presentation
of the story worthy of how much
mental space these characters took up in
our heads when we were kids and how much
they do for kids now so it was really
important to do something that was going
to have a really big epic scope that
would be immersive for the audience so
you know the use of 3d and everything we
did with the effects with the dream sand
and the snow and and all of that you
know our whole um
our whole idea was to take the idea that
people believe in these characters very
seriously and say that that is how we
want the movie itself to relate to the
audience by kind of bringing you into it
and making our town as realistic as
possible you know there's peeling paint
and there's
you know old cars on the street there's
you know you can see the there's all the
lights in the windows and whatnot uh by
making all the guardians worlds as rich
and as
fully uh
immersive and surrounding as we could
make them as real as we could this movie
for all intents and purposes is a visual
effects movie if it was shot live action
and i was at digital domain i would have
fought to get this movie
to be honest with you um it it just is
that kind of moving it's shot that way
and it feels that way once we know what
the character design is
um and we don't like to design our
characters based on what an actor looks
like we these are our characters that we
create and once we had them
we put together the list of the actors
we thought had the right voice and the
right tone and the right
heart and um
they all said yes we went to each of
them and showed them designs and
drawings and then the easter bunny kind
of you know we knew hugh was going to be
involved and uh
i guess it kind of came about us
thinking about what the character of the
bunny was going to be that it was going
to be a little more of like a cowboy
kind of tracker kind of ornery kind of a
guy and i guess we ended up like
actually listening to the australian
accent from australia where he had
played a character that was very close
to what bunny was going to be and it
just felt like well that fit yeah let's
just have to do that you know and
there's a series of 13 books that are
being released i think about six are out
right now
and so he was as he was writing the
mythologies in the deep deep background
for all the characters we were
developing the movie but
he's been incredibly involved for the
last four years and he's so happy and
thrilled with how it how it turned out
it's you know a labor of love for him
and for us but it was a great
collaboration they kind of complement
each other more than one is based on the
other so it worked really well actually
you know we were showing him all of our
artwork and he'd chime in and you know
he and i would talk about movie
references yeah and the designs are all
based on his early early designs that he
had been carrying around him for 20
years so they're very closely integrated
guillermo who's like you know he's a lot
like north in the movie you know he's a
big guy really excited and passionate
and full of energy and and and he was
like the greatest cheerleader and the
greatest support and you know shoulder
to cry on and uh was always there to
make sure that we were you know staying
passionate about the things we had been
passionate about in the first place and
uh not let go of the uh
the uh the great stuff i mean and all
the stuff that meant something to him
the magic and the fantasy and the
the the childhood stuff was the same
stuff that we loved